so I went to comic books back then a lot  of companies look down on comic books I  bought something like 3.2 million pages  of comic book advertising a year hey it  worked beautifully  he hired Joe Orlando later  vice-president of EC Comics to draw the  advertisements those Joe Orlando images  are iconic beyond belief but the ad copy  that was all heralds and heralds really  had a voice bubbling over with  spectacular tricks these tiny talented  troopers perform like will psychist us  what's the comic antics of these  fantastic underwater balloons that are  actually really alive order now only a  dollar plus 25 cents shipping  you